[Musique]
on a attaqué un hôpital on a agressé son
personnel soignant c'est unir une
intrusion violente
avez-vous dit successivement monsieur le
ministre c'est un acte scandaleux
avez vous ajouté monsieur le premier
ministre c'est une exactions
inqualifiables et indigne d'après la
ministre de la santé
quant au président de l'assistance
publique
l'ancien ministre le guen il a ajouté
c'est un acte de pure barbarie
alors monsieur le ministre sur quels
faits le gouvernement s'est-il fondé
pour donner l'alarmé français sur des
violences qui n'ont pas eu lieu
que s'est il passé exactement à la pitié
salpêtrière le 1er mai et si vous avez
été induit en erreur par de fausses
informations
quelles conséquences en avez-vous tiré
les responsables hospitaliers qui m'ont
accueilli m'ont fait part de leur
émotion
et c'est sur la base de leurs émotions
qui d'ailleurs était filmé par les
chaînes d'information que je me suis
prononcé et c'est sur la base de cette
émotion extrêmement forte que j'ai
dénoncé ces faits parce que monsieur
philippe bas vous le savez jamais je
crois dans l'histoire d'une
manifestation
on a eu ce genre de situation où on a pu
successivement attaqué un commissariat
une école et rentrer de force puisqu'il
ya eu bris de serrure joconde ans à
l'hôpital
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
utilisé ce mot qui au vu des événements
le lendemain mais surtout au vu de la
polémique qui ont été menées et qui
mettait du coup en cause la qualité
exceptionnelle du travail nos forces de
sécurité j'ai souhaité faire évoluer le
mot en prenant celui de la directrice et
donc d'évoquer une intrusion
sur twitter monsieur castaner d'abord
évoqué une attaque contre l'hôpital de
la pitié salpêtrière et a même affirmé
que nos forces de l'ordre sont
intervenues pour servais sauver le
service de réanimation
or les faits et rien que les faits
démontrent le contraire
la crédibilité du miz de l'intérieur qui
a manipulé l'opinion est aujourd'hui
entaché pour le moins il devrait être
entendu par les commissions des lois du
parlement
trop de blessés y compris parmi les
policiers
trop de violence devrait vous inviter
monsieur le premier ministre à revoir
votre doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
allez vous monsieur le ministre enfin
répondre à cette exigence
le cas de cette intrusion et de cette
intrusion violente dans l'hôpital la
pitié salpêtrière c'est une intrusion à
l'évidence est à l'évidence un certain
nombre de gens qui étaient présents sur
les lieux ont d'abord dit que cette
intrusion violente leur avaient leur
avait donné le sentiment que le
fonctionnement normal du service de
réanimation lequel est évidemment
sensible je pense que vous en
conviendrez allait être mis en cause et
que cela aurait pu avoir des
conséquences catastrophiques
compte tenu de ces informations compte
tenu de ces informations
le ministre de l'intérieur a fait une
déclaration très rapidement le lendemain
il a indiqué qu'il avait contenu ce
qu'ils savaient utiliser une expression
qui n'était pas adapté
madame la présidente je voudrais dire
une chose et une chose très simple avoir
un mot qui n'est pas adapté quand on est
un responsable public ça arrive c'est
courant ça m'est arrivé est peut-être un
jour cela vous arrivera t'il le corriger
le corriger en assumant d'avoir utilisé
un terme qui n'était pas adapté et en
revenant un terme qu'il est parfaitement
fait honneur à celui qui le fait est une
bonne chose et me semble à la hauteur de
ce que doit faire un responsable
politique et je veux à cette occasion
redire toute ma confiance en monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]